while I morghulis but why ms oh my god
law I submitted by bond James Bond a
woman was arrested for trespassing three
days in a row at the CIA headquarters
that's how good their security is they
[ __ ] trespass three days in a row
maybe she stepped one foot on the lawn
and she got tackled ready or maybe she's
outside just going like this like even
would you do that you got dancer swag
swag look yes woman her name is Jennifer
she's 58 years old of North Carolina
she went to Virginia four times I'm
listening
okay so she went and as she walked into
the visitor center and then she
explained to the officer that she had
applied for employment at the CIA and
that her recruiter directed her to go
into the agency that's smart but then
she was told that she was trespassing
and associated her walking away and then
the next time she went she's just trying
to get a job that first day was on April
22nd the second time was on me yeah so
then she was sitting in the rear seat of
a lift and then a videophone she told
the officer she was there to meet her
recruiter and then she received a
written warning for trespassing on that
property someone wrote on a napkin
warning so she said that if she returns
she will be cited for trespassing needed
to go to her job interviews so then the
next day on May 2nd she arrived in an
uber and she says she could you change
brands yeah so again same thing she
wanted to speak to a recruiter so she
knew to go to the headquarters because
her phone was off and so she ended up
being cited for trespassing
finally on May 3rd she showed up at the
Visitor Center again and requested to
speak to agent penis
agent penis this is what happened
detective Joe on the way to solve this
crime she's been bamboozled because this
guy he's been like
having sex with her and he's like I'm a
spy CIA agent Peters now they call me
agent penis
you want some agent penis and then they
have sex and [ __ ] and he's like and
she's like when am I ever gonna be able
to meet our freakin CIA buddy I just
come to Virginia and then you could meet
me later and then she's like okay I
gotta see agent penis again cuz he
hasn't called me in two weeks and then
she's out there looking for Asian penis
which is near a crime solved all right
so then mr. police ordered her to leave
and then they asked her how do you plan
on leaving and so she said that she's
gonna take the bus you take her unicorn
back because so she was at the bus stop
for several minutes
and then when the bus arrived she asked
the officers do you really think I'm
gonna leave whoa crazy they warned her
if you don't get on the bus you will be
arrested she said I'm not leaving so she
was arrested what a Bellas are way to
get invited cuz then she's like she gets
arrested and did they take her inside
the CIA into the jail she's a human
virus in the movie that's like those
movies where like they purposely get go
to prison so then they can like do some
[ __ ] from within like that one would
draw Butler that movie Oh a citizen
remember the snakes eat steak see tell
Frisco spoiler alert
that was a good ass movie that steak was
so delicious looking dull Frisco's and
it wasn't that good dog oh he wasn't
we all did in Vegas it was the Fresco's
they lied to us
what's the joint that we always go to
Vegas no tacos all mortal goes right no
that's not del frisk there a couple
times dry-aged place so one is inside
the new york new york hotel I forgot
yeah it's a lot of meat though she was
charged with trespassing
she's just domed what's the why that's
why the thing is but why news I don't
know the way I told you guys the reason
yeah Jon told her or there's another
reason she's just batshit crazy and she
thinks she's supposed to be part of the
CIA
yes oh she was she was released upon the
conditions of getting mental health
testing and any treatment as directed by
the courts pretrial service department
and she's also ordered to not physically
appear at CA buildings or property I
mean they didn't stop her the first four
warnings why would anyone want to work
so badly for the CIA that's the amount
of confidence she has that's pretty
tight 58 year old huh what kind of
person wants to be a spot I put that
maybe that will chase it's like hey am I
good enough true say good I do it oh
yeah that's true it's like a hacker that
gets recruited maybe that's like the
actual like it's a real recruitment
thing and recruiters it's like yeah get
through I'll be super tired
yeah see that's not what I was y'all
ready no yeah I feel like in LA
unless you're a child you're not allowed
to want to be a spy or else you're a
loser
really what is my kids no no that's I
say if you're a child only drew towns
like oh right right but if you're an
adult and you want to [ __ ] [ __ ]
does it happen like that in a real world
I want to be like the supremacy what's
that with it white supremacy
that's a terrible one though no in terms
of like why the why you chose to do it
for like $4 for his country and then it
was like gets a you know memory you know
who I want to be I want to be Denzel
Washington where he's all fat and
kicking everybody's ass no no the
equalizer to equalize I can watch it can
I tell you somebody khawaja two by far
one of be worst films I've ever seen
Tara buddy told me I was good that's
pretty bad equalizer one is way more
entertaining who was terrible why he got
fat and what it just didn't it was just
all over the place he's gonna make any
sense they said you know why it's cuz
Denzel should actually wrote it - yeah
Antoine Fuqua you know [ __ ] training
day yeah yeah he was the director who is
this guy it was it was Antoine Fuqua and
Denzel Washington who-who Fuqua you know
the guy who played the teenager in
moonlight you don't here's there anytime
you have a teenager yeah yeah yeah he
played that the reformed kid that
obviously Denzel Washington's gonna come
in and change his life over but he had
to do a line where he he's basically
playing like this young thuggish kid but
it was so put on it was a terrible it
was like yo
the McColl yo you gonna pay me to paint
these war the war was like that and
extra-urban himself yeah and in the in
the fear that we're watching everybody's
went oh my god just like that everybody
that because it was so cringy badges mr.
McCaul i they consistently said that
line i and he would have to paint this
wall for him to get some money and there
was a scene where they had this moment
where denzel washington is being Denzel
Washington where he's talking to him in
a very serious manner but he grabs the
back of his neck he's an inch away from
his face you know you want to do this
life huh you want to live this life you
want to be a gangster he gets a gun to
his face yeah this is what's like to be
a gangster it was just so [ __ ] corny
doing um everybody was watching that
film in the theater and they were just
rolling their eyes that's how bad it was
yeah well I took a [ __ ] Ray with me
and he's like a he's like a movie buff I
feel so bad he was so mad at me well is
he still standing this [ __ ] does
not sit ever
he's a flamingo like I [ __ ] you not if
we're an ostrich for sure I have seen
him stand through two movie straight at
her house wait what like I should do not
dance in the corner always stand he's an
editor too so maybe that's why he
doesn't like to sit so in the theatre he
won't say the reason why he doesn't do
is because he always sits down because
he edits edits sound all the time so
he's Mel it's possible why don't you
just give us Danny desk I don't know I
think it's expensive
you had one I broke this why don't get
standing just anymore because once it
breaks it's just a regular desk that's
very awkward I had that one for Mike
here and it just kind of went half way
up so it's just had this weird weird
[ __ ] huh you sitting down here like
this yeah I couldn't sit or stand so it
at a point I was literally on my desk
doing this yeah it was either that or I
was doing this Oh dad yeah
and then I [ __ ] you not I should have
[ __ ] did it insta story about this
because it was so hilarious I finally
got it to work and then but when I press
the down button it got stuck sewing
straight to the [ __ ] floor so was it
the desk this tall oh [ __ ] it was a desk
this [ __ ] tall and so I just do the
whole thing
to go that low I don't know but the down
button broke and so just when the scene
how's it wait it's going this [ __ ]
love so I to sit down on my house and
work on the computer additional Quran
stuff Oh me for you never get the white
IKEA [ __ ] mobile desk it's terrible
the black point yeah
anyway we're talking about this lady oh
the CIA lady yeah I forgot about her
stomach cool yeah that's it
[Music]